d'autres mondes suffisance aujourd'hui
sur super mario pour l'épisode 3 on est
au niveau numéro 7 et j'espère que ça va
être plus facile que niveau d'avant qui
serait d'ailleurs la loi est logique
alors c'est parti apparemment d'être sur
une ligne droite avec des picards bah
oui faut reprendre les bonnes habitudes
j'avais oublié alors ya sûrement des
pays qui les troubles voilà un [ __ ]
alors attendez on va essayer d entre
l'époux gère encore faut-il y rajoutant
le maire demandait ce que j'adore la
kermesse et que tu commences le jeu tu
as plutôt tendance à rigoler et puis tu
le fais et puis tu le fini et tu as
plutôt tendance à tva
mais [ __ ] en mai ok j'ai compris j'ai
compris milieu de fougères non officiel
durcit [ __ ] mieux à gérer avec qui
nous font des smileys et maintenant 20
secondes dans la peau des nuages donnent
faire mario c'est nous qui traite de
puteaux comme ça lui mais se prend pour
qui la non mais c'est clair en plus pour
un mec qu'a pas changé sa casquette
depuis 40 ans avale pas plus à chaque
épisode et nous critique alors qu'on est
juste là pour leur remonter le moral ce
n'importe quoi oui elle fut là encore la
boucle laisse alors que les mets plus à
la mode fait égal tués
c'était 20 secondes dans la cause des
nuages de ne faire mario ça sûrement le
faire partir de la 370e milliards
quatrième fois juste x 46 8212 la mer
j'espère juste ne pas casser la barre
mais [ __ ] mais je suis trop ici
j'avais toujours la même chose
milieux milieu fougères la [ __ ] de
cette année je détestais les fougères
jeudi mais on fait une pause
je reviens dans 10 minutes et paris qu'à
force de jouer on développe des
d'espèces de symptômes de schizophrénie
voix ya des gens qui font déjà parler
eux-mêmes tu vois c'est bizarre tout ça
c'est aussi tu comprends pas pourquoi
des gens qui deviennent schizophrène
dangereux
bon là c'est là que vient le moment un
peu tout l'astuce de 2 fr mario c'est de
garder son calme
surtout garder son calme ah voilà par
exemple on va il faut plutôt rigoler de
c'est la réaction et barbe l'epita
j'adore
va te faire semblant et non mais [ __ ]
mais là il boxe de jeu elle a plu chez
asos d'une personne guidera et je saute
niglis pas homo je vous montrais comme
par hasard au non non non non ça c'est
dégueulasse n'empêchera en rien mais ces
pics là qui se cachent dans les buissons
d'un an mon dieu c'est [ __ ] de temps à
passer son affreuse je parie qu'un trou
des pics quelque part entre ces mille
pattes
on va essayer dès qu'ils viennent c'est
pire ce que je pensais j'écris une
chanson dans mon désespoir et pourquoi
je chante je ne sais pas
à des pics cachés dans les foules hier
le trouve avant les foules hier
oh ça va pas du tout je pense qu'on peut
peut-être s'en sortir enfin technique
x-men ma fac à aubes atteint ce piège
n'était même pas connu des autorités de
and fair mariona tan tan tan l'uqar et
garde ton calme au ta mère tu croyais
m'avoir pervers là mon avis en fait ok
je pense savoir ce qu'il faut faire
via la fougère les fougères sont très
trompeuse d'enjeu a alors je pense que
en fait faute au bon moment genre la
jeune accouchée même pas regardé geler
tout je peux pas eu l ado alors attendez
attendez attendez attendez hommes et non
mais je vous promets que ce perso glisse
un mario marche sur des savonnettes
[ __ ] mais refaite line up de jeux à
boucher les trous et coupez les pics
mais tu veux faire un vrai chantier sur
sur ce jeu [ __ ] mais je comprendrais
jamais le maître a créé jeu voilà voilà
il aimait les piquer des trous s'est dit
on va faire mario avec des pics et des
trous mais ça va être super marrant on
va faire rage et où tu les paies anti du
monde entier et je suis beaucoup moins
inquiet parce que j'aime le lait entier
pas drôle alors si on y va là bas au nom
au nom au non en fait je pense que c'est
wolverine qui en dessous la terre et tu
fais chennai qui s'amuse jamais arrivé
si là ok mais [ __ ] tu exploses de
merde mais ça remet les mêmes que ça
chauffe à ce duo car je veux mettre au
yoga
cette fois on met une musique épique on
y arrive c'est parti
mais musique de pics ne marche pas du
tout je n'abandonnerai jamais mon
t-shirt sur un repli de sueur tout le
monde dira que je serai le m tout le
monde sauf tout le monde
maman tu m'as mis au monde dans un seul
but près aussi refaire mario alors
aubade a fait ma lettre d'adieu à tous
et à toutes
c'est là que tout ce jeune homme et
[ __ ] mais vous verrez
mais jouer ici à ce jeu et regarder la
maniabilité de merde mais de merde
autant faut jamais tenter des choses
dans ce jeu c'est enfin ce programme des
pics dans qu aux âmes au métro est tombé
de haut
alors c'était digne de dos chez kodak
hier il a coûté après une belle bataille
un appel oui il me semble ouais ça va
j'étais en vidéo là j'étais en train de
rage et où tu me sauvage et adore
regarder où nous sommes dans le jeu nous
avons passé les hommes 40 pouces et qui
nous font chier à chaque fois et tout ça
en étant téléphonera je trouve ça un peu
gros alors je viens je suis un peu où
étaient les piques
on va essayer d'aller aux mondieux up
quant aux la vache au sec
à cette déception a un c'est trop dur
c'est trop dur
yamada bagadig pièce
oh non faut juste suivre la date
carapace en sabrant d'âge panasonic aux
états mais elles touchent pas [ __ ]
faut dire en quelle langue de lobbies
touche de gloss tous nos canaux ses
oeuvres jusqu'au nord-ouest et auxonne
bon os
c'est aussi douloureux que ces pygmées d
entre eux heureusement j'aime et un
t-shirt pas montrer mes auréole et
croyez moi que vous en avez pas rigoler
à mada fracas puis devoir attendre ses
carottes pas cela qui font la queue leu
leu
pourquoi elles sont là qu'est ce
qu'elles veulent on ne sait pas ce que
vous achetez du pommeau non non ne sais
pas abada paca pourquoi mais pourquoi
mais qu'a créé ça c'est quoi l'idée
donner des maux à vache au parricide
checkpoint je suis sûr que c'est du fait
qu'il faut passer là comme ça aux maths
on s'en bat les couilles
un verbe
oh la la
non non non là on finit l'on finit là on
finit au mais arrête là d'accord il a
sorti un pic de sa poche
est ce que c'est un pickpocket est-ce
qu'on va y arriver
dites-moi envoie voyant 72 83 83 12 euro
par sms puis structuration
oh [ __ ]
jean thomas mangani je tombe vous tombez
nez